Our world is changing.
A dark cloud has descended upon the undersea kingdom.
I feel the tide shifting.
I'm supposed to be the king
to bring the land in the sea together.
I'm going to kill Aquaman
and destroy everything he holds dear.
I'm going to murder his family
and burn his kingdom to ashes.
He must be stopped.
The global meltdown is imminent.
I think I know someone who might be able to help us.
It's not going to like it.
Cool.
You look rough.
You have a brother.
Hi, Frank.
Do not call me brother. I'm
I cannot believe you let this happen.
Perhaps you should leave
and let someone who knows what they're doing
be king.
I cannot wait to throw your ass back in prison.
So over.
We need to find Manta.
He's different now.
Be stronger than before.
It's the black Trident
doing King Atlantis time.
There were seven kingdoms
who tried to force a curse upon them.
my God.
Pick a fight.
Fine.
Flex your muscles.
I don't know what lies ahead,
but we can't leave our children in the world.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my brand new Aquaman 2 trailer video.
Jason Momoa also talking about coming back
as Lobo inside the DC Universe.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The main man is going to wreck the new version
of the Justice League in the new Superman.
and because Aquaman two is coming out within the week.
As of be posting this video,
I will give away a couple of tickets.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just let me know
what you want them to do with the new version of Lobo,
Jason Momoa.
When he comes back in the DC movies,
he's basically said that he will come back
like DC Warner Brothers is always his home in
there was there for a brief hot second
there was a chance he could come back as Aquaman
in the new DCU under James Gunn's new DC movies.
Bulge. A lot of that depended on Aquaman.
Two earning over like $1,000,000,000,
like the first movie earned over $1,000,000,000 it,
even if you're not a box office genius, like you don't
really get into the weeds on stuff like that.
With movies, it is not looking good for Aquaman two.
Just in general.
I think people are ready to see
what these new DC movies are going to look like
with, like all this brand new stuff
that they're working on behind the scenes.
so in response to the box office projection
Jason Momoa is like is not looking
good like he's taking it all in stride
like he's been a real champ about it.
looking too good. that Lobo cover and I was like, Wow,
look at the guy.
Look at the guy.
I was a big Lobo fan growing up,
so I have every comment.
So that But if you're not familiar with the Lobo
character, he's essentially an incredibly powerful
Ghanian bounty hunter who just loves wrecking stuff,
causing mayhem behind the scenes.
I wouldn't call him a villain or hero.
He kind of has a neutral alignment.
Like he can help people.
He can also work against Superman. The Justice League.
in very timely
because David Corn Sweat's new version of Superman
is going to debut during Superman Legacy
in the first new Superman Man of Tomorrow
movie Inside the Tomorrow verse of the animated movies,
They actually had him face off
against Lobo is one of his first big challenges
before he'd really figured out his powers.
their scenes together, a really good template
for what his vibe is like in the comics.
Like he works against Superman.
Like he's trying to capture Superman at first,
but then he winds up helping him.
the better a couple.
Live action versions of Lobo.
Like there was one on the Krypton series.
There was a fan film
way, way back in the day that you might have seen.
ba. Generally, I think most people agree
that Jason Momoa was born to play the Lobo character,
even though he had a lot of good moments
as the DC EU Zack Snyder version of Aquaman,
the funny thing about the main character
is that I would almost say that Patrick Wilson's ORM,
his Ocean master character, is a little bit
more like comicbook Aquaman.
but there's a bunch of brand new scenes
that they put in this last big Aquaman two trailer
like wall to wall action.
For some reason, they always make
like the last big trailers, the best ones in.
It seems like we've learned a little bit
about what's going on with the actual main villain,
Pilou Abizaid's character.
A lot of people, even myself included,
thought that he was going to be based on Mongo
because that's who ruled the lost
kingdom in the comics.
but it would've been super
weird for James Wan to spend all this
like crazy expensive, giant comic book movie
the make the main villain someone named Mongo
like nobody would take him seriously
so he didn't realize the main villain is played
by Pilou Abzug who was actually Euron
Greyjoy during the original Game of Thrones series.
And it seems like he's actually playing the brother
of the ancient king Atlan King or in the first.
this is meant to incorporate some of the more recent
comic book backstory for Aquaman's character.
So Aquaman in the comics
is not descended from King Atlan.
but during the first movie
they said that he was In the comics.
He actually comes from the bloodline of King
or and the first who actually usurped the throne
of the original Kingdom of Atlantis before it sank so
part of the idea is that in the history of Atlantis.
Yeah this whole Game of Thrones aspect
with brother against brother vying for the throne
in the original king or in the first crossbreeding
with other non Atlantean people
and it's meant to position the original King
Atlan is more of a villain of that story idea,
the general idea is to juxtaposing their back story,
fighting as brothers in the ancient kingdom of Atlantis
with the present day
bromance story between Aquaman and his brother ORM.
most the flashback footage in the trailer
makes it seem like the way the story played out
is that his brother King or in the first like this
character here, was banished from Atlantis.
Then he developed the Black Trident
and then came back with a war
against the Kingdom of Atlantis
King Atlan was ultimately able to defeat him,
broke the black trident and basically locked him
in a prison inside the Lost Kingdom
for thousands of years until Black Manta
eventually finds him
with the help of Stephen Shin's character,
who kind of accidentally falls upon the Lost Kingdom.
and he becomes sort of this resurrected curse
kind of situation where Black Manta reforge
is the black trident and it seems like black Manta
makes this bargain with him for this ultimate power
through the black Triton,
but ultimately it serves as this tool of resurrection.
Like you see all these zombies with this green flame
energy all over the place because later in the trailer
you actually see Ocean Master or however
you want to think about him with the Black Triton.
So it seems that they get it from Black Manta
at some point.
Like there's a bunch of fight scenes between Aquaman
in black manta but what might wind up happening
is that the Ancient King or and winds up
taking over or consuming black manta
or somehow he winds up coming back
using that same power
then maybe Aquaman winds up fighting him
as the actual last big battle
just because even though their positioning black Manta
is the main villain of the movie,
I really think that the pilot Abhishek's
character is the actual main villain
and I think that's why
they need the sacrifice of Aquaman's bloodline.
Like they talk about the royal bloodline that they need
and they keep threatening Aquaman's baby alchemy
and JR That's right, his name in the comics is Alchemy
and JR Essentially or Arthur Curry.
JR Black man to actually did kill his baby
in the classic comics, like a long, long time ago.
but because this movie is like the last DCU movie
like it is closing up
shop with the DCU before we start the James Gunn DCU.
I do not think they want to close the door on that
in such a dark way.
Like they don't want to end things on such a downer
kind of moment There were supposed to be
a bunch of Batman Post-Credits scenes
like they had Ben Affleck's Batman for a little while.
They had Michael Keaton's Batman for a little while.
That was all just based on the different endings
for the Flash movie and what they were going to do
to set the next Justice League movie, like the next
big crossover movies before James Gunn was hired.
So that's why you saw,
like all that footage of Jason Momoa with Ben Affleck's
Batman doing even more reshoots last year?
All right. There we go.
Thank you.
Very eyebrow.
Whoops.
Well.
You can definitely tell that Jason Momoa totally
was not supposed to post that video.
Like even Ben Affleck was like, Dude,
what are you doing?
He can't be posting this Then for whatever reason,
the studio is just like, Let's roll with it.
Like sometimes
some of the leaks that come out of these big movies.
DC Marvel, all the big studios are actually studio
Engineered leaks just to develop hype for movies.
Ryan Reynolds
just kind of did that with Deadpool three.
Like there was some information, some pictures
that started leaking out from Deadpool three.
Then Ryan Reynolds basically jumped on that
to capitalize all of that hype for Deadpool three,
I think I'm allowed to post my review for Anchorman two
at some point next week.
As soon as they let us,
I will post a review video for it.
It seems like it's going to be like a real big dumb
action movie in the tone of the first movie.
Like if you like the first movie,
you probably enjoyed this movie.
You did not like the first movie.
This movie just seems like it takes the first movie
and turns everything up to 11.
hopefully though in the next couple of months,
we'll get an official announcement
from James Gunn or DC about Jason Momoa
coming back as a version of Lobo.
I think it's going to be a while
after the movie comes out before they actually start
talking about official Lobo stuff.
in speaking of the brand new Superman legacy movie,
we actually just got our first look at Lex Luthor.
Click here to learn about all of that
and click here for my brand
new Deadpool
3 in Wolverine video for all that new footage.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys for the next one!